speaking of leisurely activities uh you
guys went snowboarding
yeah ages ago yeah i don't think we
talked about that on the podcast yeah
don't think we have no it was uh
i couldn't go to that one yeah it was my
very first
experience snowboarding how was that
it was okay so this this we i obviously
we i went before
like we remembered that the reason i
wanted to try out snowboarding was
purely because of sss and snowboard kids
on the
n64 but uh yeah the choice between going
snowboarding and going skiing and i'm
just like
100 snowboarding i want that ssx tricky
though yeah
because everyone told me that it's like
way harder to
start snowboarding like yeah like
beginners find it easier to ski but it's
like harder to master yeah whereas
snowboarding
is harder to get into but easier to
master
from what i understand roughly i think
that's true yeah
yeah i guess like so my first experience
snowboarding was that it was
okay i didn't realize how much i took
for granted
friction in my life okay like
i'm so gone how's that like i remember
the first time
um so we got all dressed up i put on all
the kit and everything
uh put on put on the snowboard on like
one shoe or one
foot or however like you lock yourself
in and then so
my first mission was to walk from where
i put my snowboard on
to the ski lift yeah i remember trying
to take trying to take my first step
immediately slip and i was like this is
a bit of a challenge in it
wait so you're telling me i'm gonna have
to go down a [ __ ] hill
when i can't even take a single step
because it's the type of movement you
never do otherwise it just seems it just
it's so unnatural
yeah right and um so i [ __ ] waddle my
way
over to the ski lift do you have your
snowboard on or is it like like
you're carrying a snowboard no i had my
snowboard on i think i had the one one
booting right right are you the one one
voodoon i had the one beating right
because
we walked over to like kind of hobbling
like that yeah we walked over to the
beginning
beginner ski lift and uh i was with uh
sydney and maelyn
and maylin's partner and and
um have a good time milan wasn't having
a good time either
um so only one of us knew how to
snowboard and so
only one of us was like showing us how
it was done and melin
melen knows how to ski but this was her
first time trying to snowboard either
right
as well so we we were i at least i had
like a fellow novice
with me right
i'm not the only one and so we waddle
over
to this uh ski lift right and so to go
to go through the gates we have to like
you know scan ourselves in
right and i'd like the problem with
being like having this big snowboard on
you is that once i start like taking a
step
sometimes i don't know how to stop right
so
so there was this [ __ ] kid in front
of me right there was this kid
[ __ ] pro snowboarder like easily goes
through the gate
i like go through the gate take my first
step and i swear to god i always
i almost fall on this kid
yeah i almost took out this [ __ ]
five-year-old in front of me yeah
frankly had it come coming luckily like
luckily mackie just like grabbed me
before like
i fell on this kid i was like god i'm i
and at this point i hadn't even got onto
the ski lift yeah um
and so that's the first step that's
that's the first step
i was on my way and i was texting how's
it going how's it going like it's hard
we'll get to that it's it's really
difficult to fall face
first up with skis yeah because you how
the [ __ ] are you gonna do that yeah yeah
snowboard is very easy oh yeah
yeah it's almost guaranteed you're gonna
fall face first
my way to the ski lift and i've never
obviously this is my first time on the
ski lift i've never like
i don't know what the right technique is
or like how to like
you because you don't think about this
thing right anything walking
easy one one foot forward next foot
forward it was like it was like i was a
baby trying to figure out how to walk
again
so i'm i'm like it's taking like all of
my mental energy just to figure out how
to stay
on two feet and then i so
the person tells me to like go to this
point here where the ski lift is going
to go and like take you up
and i'm just thinking this is this is
like this is like i
i've never like panicked before trying
to figure out how
to waddle like literally one meter
forward too fast
yeah that was probably a bit mean of him
to make you get on a [ __ ] ski lift
yeah
first thing you should have just gone
like walked up the hill a little bit and
just tried to go down
or at least get on the ski lift holding
your snowboard right
yeah can you do that yes you can do that
yeah
but clearly no one told you that you
could do that millions husband was like
nah trial by fire
will be the option yeah okay i didn't
yeah i literally didn't know that it
wasn't normally normally yeah you are
supposed to
when you're with like beginners on
snowboard what you make them do is you
just kind of make them walk up a hill
yeah like a very
very like not steep hill yeah just kind
of make them like
go down yeah yeah straight like like
horizontal horizontal yeah
perpendicular sorry yeah to the slope uh
but that was very much uh
wow okay [ __ ] that on the skill is right
now so
i was i was kind of like um i was kind
of like like a [ __ ] animal looking
over the edge
being like okay gotta go gotta go no
don't wanna go
okay let's go now and uh so i'm like i
say a waddle
um this was like me for trying to
[ __ ] ice skate over to
to like one meter ahead of me and just
stay still enough
for the ski lift to like lift my butt up
and go up so
managed to do that luckily without
without any big massive incidents
but then comes the next step but then
and
how about you get down i was having a
great time i was like okay you know what
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] slaps look at
this view look at this like
i'm having a great [ __ ] time it's
like being it's like being on a being on
a roller coaster you know when you when
you're growing up you're just enjoying
the view it's peaceful i'm just like
okay i can get into snowboarding
um
this is pretty cool um and then i get
and then i
see um where the exit is and it's it's
it gets closer and closer and then it
slowly dawns on me how do i get off
how do i how do i exit this seat that
i'm currently
sitting on right now and i see
i see the kid in front of me gets off no
problem at all and i'm just like
that looks easy that looks easy i just i
just you know i just use the momentum
that the seat
is carrying me through and i just slide
it just and just slide off
right and i'm just like cool i'm like
i'm like i'm like shadow boxing right
because i'm just i'm just like
visualizing this in my head i'm just
like
how hard can this possibly be right
right how hard can this possibly be like
in the shower i was literally psyching
myself
up and i was just like sure i can do
that like if
if a five-year-old kid can do it then i
can do it yeah and so
literally the first thing that happens
is um
the the lift goes up it starts slowing
down i'm like brilliant i'm not i'm not
even
gonna need to do this at full speed it's
going at like naught point
[ __ ] launcher i have no idea right
i i thought you just had to use momentum
just
i had no [ __ ] clue but honestly i
think i would have preferred that
because now
i had zero momentum and i'm just like
[ __ ] how do i position my feet right
and by the time i get to the point where
i need to get off i hadn't figured out
how i was going to do this
so literally the first thing that
happens is i'm i just like i put
both feet down i literally tried
huh horizontal like that yeah like that
so i was just like i was like okay so i
was like first mistake i was
i was like okay what i'm going to do is
i'm going to put
both feet down twist and then put one of
my fingers
on on the snowboard and just slightly
and just
breezily just like slide down yeah um so
that so obviously obviously that didn't
work out right yeah
first i what i did was i put first two
feet down
stood up immediate face plan
because there's this thing behind you
that's pushing you forward
yeah you gotta like shiver to the side
like this yeah you gotta shoot me like
that
and then kind of go down like that you
know it would be nice if
someone was there to teach me how it was
done i would not have done that to you
if i was there i would have told you how
they have done it but the thing is
here's the thing right we apparently
went on the beginner slope
right and then yeah that was that that
was like there was no way that this was
the [ __ ]
beginner slug and we found out
afterwards um on the second day because
me and melin
um we we weren't having a great time
trying to go down
and apparently we found the next day
that there was a slope that was
dedicated
to like people's first time trying
snowboarding right right no we didn't go
on that one we went
we went on the [ __ ] beginner slope
which was people who had already
been experienced enough to go downhill
right right
and so it was me melee and sydney and
marky are the top of this hill
maki just [ __ ] bolts down already
yeah right
and screaming at us
the vacuum is really [ __ ] fun
just go down yeah just go down just go
straight it's not hard
and monkey goes down first and tries to
like goad the rest of us into going down
i'm just like you know what guys i'm
just i'm just i'm just i'm gonna go
i'm gonna do a pro gamer move and i'm
just gonna go down
immediately start tumbling [ __ ] down
like i i i must like front flip five
[ __ ] times going down looney tunes
and i'm just like damn
snow just like in my mind i thought snow
is gonna cushion the fall
and i'm just like man this hurts way
more than i thought it was going to do
it that's cushion but like 30 yeah yeah
yeah it's
because all of the snow you're like
snowboarding on it's been like
plowed yeah it's compact it's like
jumping off your bed
onto a very flat pillow yeah it'll
cushion you
but to what extent yeah yeah i'm just
like i'm just like i i had this image in
my mind that was just like ah it's just
like
tumbling it's just like falling on
clouds
and i remember because and because of
that i like when i first went down
i i did not hold back as well i just
like [ __ ] went as fast as i can
not realizing that jesus christ not
realizing that i i i didn't
know how to break and so
and so quickly i kind of before i before
i learned how to break
um i quickly realized that the easiest
way to break was just to fall down
oh yeah i mean that's what they teach
you at first right it's like to fall
down probably
there's a reason why like if when you if
you start young particularly in skiing
and snowboarding you're gonna be really
[ __ ] like
you're gonna be so much better than
somebody learned later on just because
like when you're a kid you're fearless
yeah exactly yeah kids don't [ __ ]
know danger
like when i was a kid i was i was going
way too fast and i would just go
straight down because i was [ __ ]
stupid and that's what like i would just
like this is fun
i love going like a hundred miles per
hour yeah it's a good idea yeah
see me [ __ ] tumbling down this hill
and then i look up and making's like
alright your turn now and they're just
like no
no i don't think i will and so they
start like getting on their butts
and just like sliding it just like
slowly sliding down
a mark he's like no come on guys come on
get up
just get good get up